Les mondes perdus
D'où viennent les oiseaux ?
Et quels sont leurs ancêtres ?
Très longtemps, ces questions
sont restées sans réponse.
Leur arbre généalogique s'arrêtait
aux plus anciens oiseaux connus.
Un célèbre fossile découvert
au XIXᵉ siècle en Allemagne,
l'Archæoptéryx, dont le nom grec
signifie "aile antique".
Mais depuis 1996, des milliers
d'animaux exhumés en Chine,
révèlent de nouveaux indices
sur l'origine des oiseaux.
Ces foisonnantes découvertes prouvent
que la plupart des dinosaures,
n'étaient pas couverts d'écailles,
mais arboraient des plumes.
Certains de ces dragons à plumes
pouvaient même voler.
Les pièces du puzzle oriental
sont tellement nombreuses,
qu'elles rattachent aux oiseaux
actuels de remarquables cousins disparus,
et suggèrent de multiples
parents possibles.
Le mystère des dragons à plumes
À l'époque jurassique, la Terre change.
Il y a 200 à 145 millions d'années,
le supercontinent Pangée se fracture
pour créer plusieurs continents.
En bordure de ce monde,
la Chine et la Sibérie,
forment une immense presqu'île
au climat tempéré,
tel celui de l'Europe actuelle.
De multiples éruptions volcaniques
rythment ce morcellement des continents,
notamment en Chine.
Un paradis en suspend
peuplé d'étranges créatures.
Comme Anchiornis.
Ce dinosaure miniature dont le nom
signifie "près de l'oiseau",
est entièrement recouvert de plumes.
De la taille d'un pigeon,
il serait leur lointain ancêtre.
Tel David contre Goliath,
les descendants de ce poids plume auraient
survécu bien mieux que d'autres théropodes.
Le groupe qui inclut
tous les dinosaures carnivores.
Membre du même groupe, les Guanlongs
sont d'efficaces chasseurs,
de trois mètres de long pour 50 kilos.
Pour leur échapper, le petit dinosaure
se lance dans de court vol plané,
tandis que ses poursuivants
restent cloués au sol.
Pourtant, les Guanlongs
ont des plumes eux aussi.
À quoi leur servent-elles ?
Des volcans,
leurs cendres et leurs gaz délétères,
ont figé la vie du Jurassique
pour l'éternité,
et apportent aujourd'hui
quelques réponses.
Le paradis des dinosaures est devenu
la Pompéi des dinosaures à plumes.
On y trouve aujourd'hui une foule
d'animaux inconnus de la science,
et conservés dans leurs moindres détails.
Dans la région du Liaoning,
les paléontologues collectent
depuis 20 ans,
des milliers de spécimens enfouis
il y a des millions d'années.
Ces fossiles sont somptueux.
Leur état de conservation exceptionnel.
Un miracle dû à la finesse des sédiments
mêlant argiles et cendres volcaniques.
Ces éruptions volcaniques ont tué les
animaux et leurs corps ont été ensevelis.
Voilà pourquoi les squelettes et parfois
les tissus sont si bien préservés.
C'est pour cette raison
que nous venons sur ce site.
Le paléontologue Xu Xing
et ses collègues du monde entier,
listent ainsi dans la pierre l'histoire
chaotique du vol et de la plume.
La préservation des plumes
est vraiment étonnante.
Tels des détectives, ils scrutent les indices
pour mieux comprendre la fonction des plumes.
Et savoir comment certains dinosaures
théropodes se sont transformés,
au fil des millions
d'années en oiseaux.
La première pièce à conviction
de leur enquête,
a été découverte au XIXᵉ siècle près
de la ville allemande de Sonthofen.
À la fin du Jurassique, l'Europe
est partiellement engloutie,
sous une mer de faible profondeur
appelée la mer de Téthys.
Il y a environ 150 millions d'années,
l'Allemagne actuelle est un lagon
maculé d'îles tropicales.
Les ptérosaures,
les premiers vertébrés volants,
dominent les airs
depuis 80 millions d'années.
On en a recensé plus de 150 espèces.
Ici, le Germanodactylus,
ces reptiles volants
ne sont pas des dinosaures.
Comme chez les chauves souris,
leur aile est formée d'une fine
peau tendue sur leurs mains,
aux doigts démesurément allongés.
Cette membrane, des os creux
et des muscles conséquents,
font d'eux les maîtres du ciel.
Mais la domination aérienne des ptérosaures
est sur le point d'être remise en cause,
par les tout premiers oiseaux,
comme cet Archæoptéryx.
Un oiseau primitif dont les petites
griffes au bout des ailes,
ont éveillé les premiers soupçons
des paléontologues du XIXe siècle.
Le décor a bien changé à Sonthofen.
Le site n'est plus au bord
d'un lagon comme au Jurassique,
mais dans la campagne bavaroise.
Aujourd'hui abandonnée, cette carrière
a livré des milliers de fossiles,
parmi les plus beaux
et les plus célèbres au monde.
Eberhard Frey, plus connu
sous le nom de Dino Frey,
est spécialiste de ce gisement.
Voici le célèbre calcaire de Sonthofen.
On voit les sédiments qui sont empilés
comme les feuilles d'un livre.
Et c'est à l'intérieur des feuilles
de ce livre de pierre,
que l'on a trouvé Archæoptéryx
et de nombreux autres fossiles.
Cette roche se caractérise
par l'extrême finesse de son grain.
Dans cette boue, les fossiles ont été
préservés comme dans une boite.
Voilà pourquoi cette région nous offre une
véritable fenêtre sur la période jurassique.
Les Bavarois utilisaient ces pierres
pour carreler leur maison.
Ils ont ainsi découvert
des trésors extrêmement précieux,
dans l'histoire de la paléontologie.
En 1868, face au fossile d'Archæoptéryx,
le biologiste britannique
Thomas Henry Huxley,
affirmait que cet animal était une forme
transitoire entre dinosaures et oiseaux.
Ami de Darwin et ardent défenseur
de la théorie de l'évolution,
Huxley était un anatomiste de génie,
capable d'analyser finement les fossiles.
Jusqu'à la découverte
d'Archæoptéryx en 1861,
les seules créatures à plumes
connues étaient les oiseaux.
Et il semblait donc évident
que ce fossile soit celui d'un oiseau.
Thomas Huxley l'a observé
de très près et il a découvert,
des signes indiquant qu'il pouvait
aussi s'agir d'un dinosaure,
et même d'un dinosaure carnivore.
Il a donc les caractéristiques des deux,
faisant de lui un chaînon manquant,
entre les dinosaures et les oiseaux.
Cela fait beaucoup de bruit à l'époque.
L'idée darwinienne de la sélection
naturelle est alors très récente.
Remarquez que les dents de sa mâchoire,
les griffes au bout des ailes
et sa queue osseuse,
rapprochent Archæoptéryx des dinosaures,
cousins des Vélociraptors,
et donc extrêmement novateurs.
Archæoptéryx n'est certes
pas le meilleur des acrobates,
mais il a des plumes et il vole.
Ses clavicules ont déjà fusionnées.
Étape indispensable pour
battre efficacement des ailes,
et prendre de la hauteur.
Pour chasser, mais aussi nicher
dans les arbres.
Tout au long du XXᵉ
et même du XXIᵉ siècle,
d'autres fossiles d'Archæoptéryx
sont exhumés en Allemagne.
Voici le spécimen numéro onze,
le dernier qui a été découvert en 2011.
Et même s'il est fragmentaire
et qu'il n'a pas été entièrement conservé,
puisque le crâne manque,
il nous révèle tout de même,
des caractéristiques,
jusque-là inconnues.
On peut par exemple voir sur
ce spécimen que le bout de la queue,
présente des plumes en forme
de V et également,
que des plumes recouvrent
entièrement les pattes.
Ces plumes sont intrigantes,
car les pattes des oiseaux
actuels en sont dépourvues.
Est-ce une exception ?
Ce qui est certain, c'est que ce trait
n'a pas été retenu,
au fil de l'évolution.
Tout comme ce gigantesque
reptile marin.
Un Liopleurodon.
Son échouage sur la rive du lagon
est une aubaine pour Archæoptéryx.
Les mouches que sa charogne attire sont
autant de mets de choix pour cet insectivore.
Problème en vue.
Au sortir du bois,
Archæoptéryx est à découvert.
Opportuniste, un Germanodactylus ne laissera
pas passer une telle manne de protéines.
Et n'apprécie guère la concurrence.
Les ptérosaures qui dominaient les airs se
sont ensuite éteints à la fin du Crétacé,
il y a 65000000 d'années,
tandis que les descendants d'Archæoptéryx
devenaient de plus en plus nombreux.
Englué au fond du lagon de Sonthofen,
ce fabuleux fossile a ouvert le débat sur
la parenté des oiseaux avec les dinosaures.
Mais faute de preuves suffisantes,
cette théorie est ensuite tombée
dans l'oubli pendant plus de 100 ans.
Jusqu'à ce qu'un nouveau jour se lève
enfin sur l'origine des oiseaux,
à la fin du XXᵉ siècle, en Chine.
En 1993, un gisement fossilifères
est découvert dans le Liaoning,
au nord-est de Pékin.
Il date du Crétacé,
il y a 125000000 d'années.
Cette région, plus connue sous
son nom ancien de Mandchourie,
est une terre fertile,
à perte de vue s'étendent,
champs de maïs et pâturages.
Au début, ce sont d'ailleurs les paysans
qui exhument par hasard les fossiles.
Au pied de cette falaise marqué
par les éruptions volcaniques,
alternances multiples
de couches de boues grises,
et de cendres rouges.
Transporté à Pékin, ils offrent
aux chercheurs du XXIᵉ siècle,
une vue inédite sur ces animaux
aujourd'hui disparus.
Comme Sinosauropteryx.
Le premier dinosaure à plumes
décrit en 1996.
Aujourd'hui encore, il émerveille CXu Xing,
le plus renommé des paléontologues chinois.
Je me souviens parfaitement que lorsqu'on a
annoncé la découverte de ce fossile en 1996,
nous étions tous réellement passionnés
et même bouleversés,
par la beauté de ce spécimen.
Si l'on observe
ce spécimen avec attention,
on voit des plumes sur toute
la surface du corps, sur la tête,
sur le dos, sur la queue,
et même un peu ici.
Ces plumes sont assez basiques.
Elles ressemblent plutôt à nos cheveux.
Avant cette découverte, certains
paléontologues,
croyaient que les dinosaures pouvaient avoir
des plumes, mais nous n'en avions pas la preuve.
Maintenant, c'est prouvé,
donc c'est totalement différent.
Ce fossile couvert de plumes,
même basiques,
provoque un immense
étonnement car cette fois,
un dinosaure possède
un trait propre aux oiseaux,
preuve qu'ils appartiennent
à la même lignée.
Sinosauropteryx vit à l'ombre des volcans
dans les forêts de conifères.
Il fait partie du groupe des dinosaures
carnivores, les théropodes.
Des prédateurs qui chassent
à vue et au flair.
L'une de ses proies favorites
se nomme Zhangheotherium.
l'un des tout premiers mammifères.
Les plumes de Sinosauropteryx
ressemblent au duvet des poussins actuels.
Elles sont si éloignées
de celle des oiseaux,
que les incrédules
ont longtemps rétorqué,
qu'il s'agissait
de fibres de collagène.
Jusqu'à ce que Xu Xing
prouve le contraire en 2010.
Tout commence par l'observation
minutieuse de ces traces sombres.
En prélevant un échantillon
puis en le passant au microscope,
les scientifiques découvrent,
emprisonnées dans la pierre, des cellules.
Ce sont des mélanosomes, les cellules
qui donnent leur couleur aux plumes.
Ici, Xu Xing en distingue des rondes,
produisant un pigment brun,
et d'autres en forme de bâtonnets
qui créent un pigment gris.
Il en conclut que Sinosauropteryx,
avait la couleur d'un écureuil
et des stries claires sur la queue.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Les mélanosomes sont utiles
pour déterminer la couleur.
Mais nous utilisons surtout cette
information pour confirmer l'hypothèse,
selon laquelle les traces
sombres sur ce spécimen,
sont bien des protoplumes
et pas autre chose.
La présence de mélanosomes nous permet
donc d'affirmer avec certitude,
qu'il s'agit bien
de plumes primitives.
Ce sont bien des plumes
qui couvrent Sinosauropteryx,
comme les oiseaux.
Mais cet animal terrestre
est loin de pouvoir voler.
Alors à quoi lui sert ce duvet ?
À protéger du froid
cet animal à sang chaud, peut-être.
Oui, mais comment le prouver ?
Pour connaître le climat du Liaoning
à l'époque des dinosaures,
Xu Xing s'est associé
à un laboratoire français.
Cette dent de théropode rapportée de Chine
par le géologue Romain Amiot,
contient la réponse
à ce mystère météorologique.
De nombreux chercheurs pensaient
que les fossiles de l'époque,
ne pouvaient pas préserver l'enregistrement
du temps de la vie de l'Animal.
C'était un grand challenge.
On allait tester quelque chose d'inconnu.
Est-ce qu'on peut retrouver
une information climatique ou pas ?
L'eau bue par les dinosaures
est en effet parvenue jusqu'à nous.
C'est l'oxygène conservé
dans l'émail de leurs dents,
qui, par réactions chimiques,
dévoile aux chercheurs,
la température de l'atmosphère.
Il y a 120000000 d'années.
Romain fait alors une découverte majeure
qui bouscule les connaissances établies.
À cette époque-là, on avait
un climat global au niveau de la planète,
qui était similaire, voir peut être
un peu plus froid qu'actuellement.
Ce qui est vraiment différent de ce
qu'on pensait de l'époque des dinosaures,
qu'on imaginait
comme étant chaud, tropical,
et homogène à la surface de la terre,
là où se situait le Liaoning,
on avait un climat tempéré,
comme on a aujourd'hui dans le nord
de la France, avec des hivers très rigoureux.
Les dinosaures voyez sûrement
la neige chaque hiver,
la plume, c'était finalement
un tissu isolant,
quelque chose qui leur permettait de se
tenir chaud et d'avoir une activité physique,
soutenue tout au long de l'année,
comme n'importe quel animal à sang chaud.
Coïncidence, alors que Romain publie
tout juste ses résultats en 2012,
la découverte de dinosaures
de très grande taille,
près de dix mètres de long,
abonde en son sens.
Les Yutyrannus, superprédateurs
de l'époque,
sont nommés à juste titre
les tyrans à plumes.
Les restes de ces cousins
du célèbre T.Rex,
sont conservés dans un hangar
en banlieue de Pékin,
en raison de leur taille impressionnante.
Yutyrannus est un animal
vraiment extraordinaire.
Il est tellement énorme que sa masse
corporelle peut atteindre 1,5 tonne.
Son corps est couvert de plumes
très longues, ce qui est très inattendu.
Habituellement, quand un animal gagne
en taille et chez les dinosaures,
ça se passe de la même façon,
les plumes se raréfient
ou sont vraiment dispersées.
Mais dans ce cas-là, le corps énorme
d'un dinosaure possède des plumes,
à la fois longues et denses.
C'est donc très bizarre.
Si un animal aussi grand était
entièrement couvert de plumes,
c'est que son corps massif
ne suffisait pas à réguler sa température.
Il devait donc faire très froid.
La découverte du plus immense animal
à plumes jamais identifié,
confirme ainsi l'idée d'un climat
tempéré aux hivers rigoureux.
Elle prouve que les dinosaures
théropodes du Liaoning,
déambulaient dans la neige en hiver,
il y a 125 millions d'années.
Et que les plumes
des petits Sinosauropteryx,
comme celle des gros Yutyrannus
les protéger du froid hivernal,
dans cette région de l'hémisphère nord.
Cette fonction isolante de la plume
persiste chez les oiseaux actuels,
mais elle n'est pas suffisante pour expliquer
comment des dinosaures vivants au sol,
ont évolué durant des millions d'années
pour devenir les oiseaux.
Parmi les théropodes vivant dans le Liaoning,
il y avait il un seul type de plumes ?
Et quand les dinosaures ont-ils
commencé à voler ?
Au fil des ans,
des paléontologues chinois,
ont exhumé de multiples
créatures à plumes.
Sur certains fossiles
comme celui de Caudipteryx,
Xu Xing à découvert en 1998,
bien plus que de simples filaments.
Avec ses grandes pattes,
cet animal ressemble à une autruche.
Sur ce fossile, il y a
de magnifiques traces de plume.
On voit les deux pattes de cet animal.
Ici, le doigt du milieu
et les plumes rattachées à ce doigt,
sur toute cette surface.
Elles vont d'ici à là.
Donc ce sont d'assez grandes plumes.
Ce Caudipteryx,
littéralement queue à plumes,
provient du même site chinois
que Sinosauropteryx.
Il date lui aussi du Crétacé,
il y a 125000000 d'années.
Les scientifiques imaginent
que ces poussins,
étaient imprégnés des cris de leur mère,
comme ceux des oiseaux modernes.
Ils devaient la suivre partout,
ou presque.
La femelle qui pèse près
de 20 kilos ne peut pas voler.
Idem pour ses petits.
Alors, pourquoi ces animaux
ont-ils de longues plumes ?
Auraient-elles une autre utilité
que l'isolation thermique ?
Dans la vie d'une plume,
tout commence par un simple filament,
qui se divise pour former un pompon,
avant que les barbes s'insèrent de part
et d'autre du rachis tubulaire.
Mais à ce stade de développement,
la plume est symétrique,
et l'air passe à travers.
Cet animal ne vole pas,
il court vite et vit à terre.
Quelle est donc la fonction de ces plumes,
qui ne sont visiblement
pas utilisées pour voler.
L'autre possibilité, selon
l'hypothèse la plus répandue,
c'est qu'elle servait pour la parade.
Comme chez de nombreux oiseaux, mâles
et femelles étaient bien différents.
Les paléontologues pensent
que les mâles Caudipteryx,
exhibait leurs plumes chatoyantes
pour obtenir les faveurs des femelles.
Ces parades nuptiales
et la sélection naturelle,
auraient même favorisé
une transformation anatomique.
Les Caudipteryx, sont parmi
les premiers théropodes,
à posséder une queue plus courte sur
laquelle se fixent leurs plumes d'apparat.
Mais pour voler,
il leur manque encore le principal.
Des plumes adaptées.
Justement, cette plume
observée au microscope,
est celle d'un autre dinosaure
découvert par Xu Xing, lui-même, en 2000.
C'est une preuve clé pour percer
le mystère de l'origine du vol.
Et si les plumes sont
vraiment asymétriques,
Or, les plumes asymétriques
sont généralement associées,
à la capacité à voler.
Ces plumes sont identiques
à celles des oiseaux actuels.
Est-ce le signe que ce dinosaure
était capable de voler ?
Microraptor est très certainement l'espèce
la plus étonnantes découvertes à ce jour.
Il s'agit d'un dinosaure, mais il
possède des plumes asymétriques,
pas seulement sur les pattes d'avant,
mais aussi sur ses pattes arrières.
Nous appelons ça,
le stade quatre ailes.
C'est vraiment très étrange, mais nous
avons des preuves que ce stade quatre ailes,
est lié à l'origine du vol.
Les paléontologues pensent depuis
longtemps que les dinosaures bipèdes,
couraient au sol pour décoller,
mais avec Microraptor,
qui grimpe à l'aide de ses griffes,
une nouvelle piste d'apparition
du vol est dévoilée.
Dans la Chine qu'habite Microraptor,
il y a 125 millions d'années,
les cendres volcaniques
fertilisent les sols,
et favorisent une végétation exubérante.
Les grands arbres ajoutent
une nouvelle dimension,
la verticale, dont le Microraptor,
littéralement, le petit voleur,
fait sa spécialité.
Ses plumes lui servent pour la parade.
Pour se tenir chaud
et enfin pour voler.
Quatre ailes,
c'est un avantage pour planer,
mais un handicap pour marcher.
Un Microraptor au sol
est un Microraptor en danger de mort.
Selon Xu Xing, ce sont de petits
dinosaures arboricoles,
tels celui-ci qui aurait
évolué vers l'oiseau.
Pour mieux comprendre cette transition,
le paléontologue collabore
avec un ornithologue,
Zhou Zhongue.
Face à lui, une incroyable collection
d'oiseaux primitifs découverts,
comme les dinosaures à plumes
issus du même site.
Ils datent du Crétacé,
il y a 125 millions d'années.
Je pense qu'il y a plus de 500 specimens
de Confuciusornis réunis dans ce musée.
C'est l'une des plus importantes
collection de Confuciusornis au monde.
Les oiseaux comme Confuciusornis,
apparaissent peu de temps,
après Archæoptéryx, le premier oiseau.
Leurs traits morphologiques adaptés
au vol sont en voie de transition.
Excepté leurs griffes au bout des ailes,
ils sont très proches
des oiseaux actuels.
Ils n'ont plus de dents au bec.
Ni de longue queue osseuses.
Ils possèdent aussi un bréchet,
le fameux os à souhait des poulets,
sur lequel s'attachent
les muscles des ailes.
Et chez les mâles, deux rubans d'apparat
ornent leur croupion.
Ce fort dimorphisme sexuel,
rappelle celui du dinosaure
à plumes Caudipteryx.
Comme lui, le mâle est paré de longues plumes
qu'il utilise pour courtiser les femelles.
Mais la concurrence est rude,
et la parade nuptiale
souvent perturbée.
Vous voyez aussi l'oiseau commencé
à grimper aux troncs des arbres,
grâce aux grandes griffes de ses ailes.
L'oiseau peut désormais
se percher sur les branches,
car l'orteil de son pied
est déjà inversé,
comme chez les oiseaux modernes.
Les plumes étroites des Confuciusornis,
ne sont pas bien adaptés au vol plané,
mais devaient leur permettre de voler
en battant des ailes, même maladroitement.
La sélection naturelle est à l'oeuvre,
et retient les gènes les plus habiles.
Pourtant, cette affluence d'oiseaux,
la même où vivaient les dinosaures à plumes,
ne prouve pas automatiquement
qu'ils soient leurs ancêtres.
Car si les oiseaux s'étaient déjà
diversifiés, il y a 125 millions d'années,
les Yutyrannus et autres théropodes,
pourraient-ils n'être
qu'une impasse de l'évolution ?
Alors de quand date
les tout premiers oiseaux ?
Ont-ils un ancêtre commun
avec les dinosaures à plumes ?
Et comment le vol a-t-il débuté
chez leurs ancêtres ?
Pour répondre à ces questions,
les paléontologues chinois,
possèdent une dernière carte à abattre.
Dans l'ouest de la région du Liaoning,
un nouveau gisement
de fossiles a été découvert,
lors de la construction d'une autoroute.
C'est tout près d'ici
qu'en 2009 a été exhumé,
le fossile d'Anchiornis
datant du Jurassique.
Une pièce essentielle pour
les recherches menées par Xu Xing.
Ce site est de première importance
pour au moins une raison,
nous savons qu'Archæoptéryx,
le plus ancien oiseau connu,
vivait il y a 145 millions d'années,
mais la plupart des autres dinosaures
à plumes vivaient au Crétacé inférieur,
ou même plus tard.
Or, le dinosaure
découvert ici vivait lui,
il y a 160 millions d'années,
donc avant Archæoptéryx.
Cela signifie que certains dinosaures
à plumes sont antérieurs à Archæoptéryx,
ce qui est une succession
chronologique logique.
Ce nouveau fossile
clôt enfin la polémique.
Les dinosaures à plumes seraient bien plus
anciens que les tout premiers oiseaux.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un poisson
que Xu Xing découvre.
Preuve de la richesse de l'écosystème
dans lequel vivait Anchiornis.
Ce petit théropode à quatre pattes
devait être victime de prédateurs géants.
Les ptérosaures comme ces Darwinopterus,
régnaient sur les ciels jurassiques.
Avec leur envergure voisine d'un mètre 20,
et leurs griffes
semblables à des cerfs,
ce sont les rapaces de l'époque.
Ils sont capables de vol battu
et d'acrobatie,
comme aucun dinosaures à plumes.
Face à cette menace permanente,
Anchiornis devait utiliser
le couvert de la forêt.
Pour ce petit dinosaure,
le danger vient également du sol.
Il lui reste comme protection,
l'étroit habitat entre ciel et terre.
Les arbres.
Pour aller se nourrir
au sol, il plane.
Sa surface portante étant plus
petite que celle de Microraptor,
il devait chuter plus rapidement.
Grâce à ses membres
postérieurs très élancés,
Anchiornis pourrait sprinter au sol,
mais ses longues plumes l'encombrent.
Il se sert de ses pattes
pour dénicher ses repas,
ou tenter de rejoindre
l'abri le plus proche.
Mais existe-t-il seulement ?
Même maladroitement, Anchiornis
montre que les dinosaures,
se seraient essayés au vol depuis
les arbres, avec quatre ailes.
Sur ce rarissime fossile,
les plumes des pattes arrières
sont bien visibles à l'oeil nu.
Pour affiner sa théorie,
Xu Xing poursuit ses recherches
via un scanner médical.
Les images rayons X
du squelette d'Anchiornis,
seront ensuite numérisées
en 3D pour étudier sa biomécanique.
Honnêtement, il existe des débats
pour savoir comment ces animaux,
utilisaient leurs pattes ailées.
Certains pensent que ces ailes
ne sont pas liées au vol,
mais peut-être à la parade.
Si l'on regarde l'ensemble des dinosaures,
leurs jambes sont normalement
sous leur corps.
Ils ont une posture debout.
Anchiornis avait peut-être la capacité de
légèrement projeter ses jambes sur le côté.
Pour compenser l'absence du bréchet,
l'Anchiornis utilisait les plumes
de ses pattes arrière,
pour ajouter de la finesse
à son vol plané.
Sa découverte prouve que la capacité
de vol chez les dinosaures,
est le résultat de plusieurs
évolutions par tâtonnements,
de la plume et de l'anatomie.
Mais pourquoi aucun
de ces dinosaures à plumes,
n'est présent à nos côtés aujourd'hui ?
Au Musée royal de l'Ontario, à Toronto,
plusieurs chercheurs tentent d'expliquer
leur soudaine disparition,
associée à l'impact d'un astéroïde
à la fin du Crétacé.
Au printemps 2016, le paléontologue
David Evans et ses collègues,
publient le résultat
d'une minutieuse étude.
Afin d'élucider le mystère fondamental
de l'extinction des dinosaures,
nous avons étudié les dents
de beaucoup de maniraptors,
des petits dinosaures
ressemblant aux oiseaux,
comme ceux du biotope
de Jehol en Chine.
Et nous avons cherché à comprendre,
pourquoi ces groupes se sont éteints,
alors que les oiseaux
modernes ont survécu,
à l'extinction de masse qui a marqué
la fin de l'âge des dinosaures.
Nous avons regardé l'élément qui a été
le plus abondamment préservé,
dans les fossiles : les dents.
Et nous avons analysé des milliers
de dents de ces dinosaures,
ressemblant aux oiseaux et les becs
de ces premiers oiseaux.
Et ce que nous avons découvert
et sans équivoque.
Ces groupes de petits dinosaures
à plumes et ces oiseaux,
étaient écologiquement très variés.
Mais un seul groupe a survécu.
Et ce sont les dinosaures que nous
voyons autour de nous aujourd'hui,
les oiseaux modernes,
au bec dépourvus de dents.
Et il se trouve qu'il est très probable
qu'ils mangeaient des graines.
Les graines sont très résistantes
à de nombreux types de catastrophe.
Si vous étiez un animal qui avait accès à ces
graines, vous aviez un avantage écologique.
Dans la période très critique des semaines et
mois qui ont suivi l'impact de l'astéroïde.
Et les oiseaux ont été en mesure
de tirer profit de cette ressource,
étant donné leur bec édenté.
Être édenté pour survivre.
Tel est le paradoxe
des dinosaures à plumes.
Les carnivores trépassent,
quand les granivores survivent.
Ces rescapés ont peut-être
d'autres ancêtres inattendus.
Les découvertes sur l'origine
de la plume ne s'arrêtent pas là.
À l'été 2013, un rebondissement a lieu.
De l'autre côté de la frontière
chinoise, en Sibérie.
C'est la première fois que des fossiles
de dinosaures à plumes sont trouvés en Russie.
Dans la steppe de Transbaïkalie,
une équipe mêlant russes et belges
rejoint le site de fouilles.
C'est grâce à des liens noués de longue
date avec des géologues locaux,
que le chef de mission, Pascal Godefroit,
paléontologue à l'Institut royal de Belgique,
a l'opportunité de participer
à cette découverte révolutionnaire.
Nous sommes ici sur le gisement de Kovytka,
au Sud-Est de la Sibérie.
Les collines derrière
moi datent du Jurassique,
entre 145 et 160 millions d'années,
et des géologues russes qui,
prospectés dans la région en 2010,
Ont trouvé les premiers ossements
de dinosaures qui se sont révélés,
extrêmement importants pour
reconstituer l'évolution du plumage,
et des plumes chez les dinosaures.
Cette annonce a attisé la curiosité
de Pascal qui a monté une équipe,
pour venir sur place
réaliser des fouilles.
C'est un travail de longue haleine car
il faut dégager les premières couches de terre,
pour accéder aux fossiles.
Au bout de plusieurs jours, le travail des
Belges commence déjà à porter ses fruits.
Assez conséquent.
Juste là, au bord.
Ici sur le bord de la plaque, vous pouvez
voir des petits filaments tout fins.
Ce sont des plumes de dinosaures.
On peut voir que les filaments
convergent vers une base.
Donc ce sont des plumes composées.
C'est une sorte de petit duvet primitif,
que l'on retrouve chez certains
dinosaures primitifs.
Comparées aux merveilles chinoises,
ces plumes ne semblent pas splendides.
Si elles suscitent
l'intérêt des paléontologues,
c'est parce qu'elles appartiennent
à une espèce animale inconnue auparavant.
À l'époque jurassique, la presqu'île
chinoise offre aux dinosaures,
de vastes forêts de conifères,
tandis qu'au nord,
l'actuelle Sibérie
forme un territoire hostile.
Il est soumis à un climat aride,
de forts écarts saisonniers
et une intense activité volcanique,
qui permet ici aussi
la conservation de précieux fossiles.
Seuls des fragments de squelette
sont trouvés à Kulinda.
Au départ, les Russes pensaient que
les plumes provenaient de fossiles d'oiseaux,
les écailles de fossiles de crocodiles,
et les ossements
d'un petit dinosaure prédateur.
Mais cette hypothèse ne collait pas,
selon Pascal Godefroit.
Il réanalyse l'ensemble des fossiles
pour donner une toute autre explication.
C'est un peu comme si vous alliez dans un
cimetière et que vous ramassiez les os en vrac.
Vous allez avoir des petits
et des grands tibias,
des petits et des grands fémurs,
mais tous ont la même morphologie.
Donc on peut dire que nous sommes en
présence d'un seul type de dinosaure,
que nous avons baptisé
le Kulindadromeus.
Grâce aux très nombreux ossements
isolés, désarticulés,
que nous avons trouvés à Kulinda,
nous savons maintenant que Kulindadromeus
était un petit dinosaure herbivore,
rapide, svelte et très agile.
C'est le tout premier dinosaure
herbivore à plumes connu.
Ses mâchoires étaient adaptées
à la consommation de végétaux.
Les Kulindadromeus vivaient en troupeaux.
À l'image des migrations de gnous
dans les plaines d'Afrique,
les transhumances de ces dinosaures
devaient entraîner dans leur sillage,
les grands prédateurs tels Sinraptor.
Ces carnivores font partie
du groupe des théropodes,
tandis que les herbivores comme
Kulinda sont des ornithischiens.
Ce sont deux branches séparées de l'arbre
généalogique des dinosaures.
C'est vraiment une révolution.
Tous les dinosaures, potentiellement,
avaient des plumes.
Les plumes seraient apparues chez
un ancêtre commun aux deux groupes.
Elles seraient aussi
anciennes que les dinosaures,
et leur apparition
pourrait remonter au Trias.
Voici plus de 220 millions d'années.
Les mésaventures
de ce troupeau d'herbivores,
ont conduit les paléontologues
vers l'origine de la plume.
Grâce au Kulindadromeus,
ils savent maintenant,
que le tout premier
des dinosaures à plumes,
l'ancêtre commun des carnivores
et des herbivores,
reste à trouver dans des couches
plus anciennes encore que le Jurassique.
Mais qui sait quels autres secrets
demeurent enfouis en Sibérie ?
Et dans quel monde perdu se cachent
encore de lointains ancêtres,
et cousins des oiseaux ?